ladies and gentlemen present the awards
for art direction and set direction we
have a brace of Award winners Joan
Fontaine and Jimmy Stewart
so is nominated for the best achievement
in art direction of a black-and-white
production are the bad on the beautiful
MGM Cedric Gibbons and Edward kerf angle
set direction
Edward B Willis and keel Gleeson carry
paramount pal Pereira and Roland
Anderson set direction Mao Curie my
cousin Rachel 20th Century Fox
Lyle wheeler and John to cure set
decoration Walter M Scott Rashomon die a
RKO Japanese Matsuyama set decoration
Matsumoto Viva Zapata 20th Century Fox
Lyle wheeler and Leland puller SEC
decoration Thomas little and Claud
carpenter the winner is Cedric Givens
and Edward Congo Edwin B Willis and Keo
Jason
I would like to except for Edwin be
wellis and thank Vincente Minnelli for
his inspiration those nominated for the
best achievement in art direction or the
color production our hands Christian
Andersen Goldwyn RKO Richard day and
claw they set direction Howard Bristol
The Merry Widow MGM Cedric Gibbons and
Paul Gross set decoration
Edwin beef Willis and Arthur cram Moulin
Rouge
Romulus United Artists for sheriff set
decoration
Marcel invested the quiet man Argosy
Republic Frank huddling set decoration
John McCarthy jr. and Charles Thompson
the snows of Kilimanjaro 20th Century
Fox
Lyle wheeler and John de Cure set
decoration Thomas little and Paul s Fox
the winners in absence of the winners
james wolf will accept the award for
paul sheriff and Marcel verities Moulin
Rouge
thank you very much this is the stuff
that was left over thank you very much
thank you very much on behalf of mr.
Foyle sherry mr. Stewart I just wanted
to ask you were you nominated for
anything uh
no were you nominated for anything no I
wasn't nominated either but I say it
doesn't make any difference whether you
win or lose it's how you play the game I
read that on Basil Rathbone shorts
you you one you never have but nominated
have you know I don't know how they
missed me but they did but I don't know
Jimmy it seems like somehow of course
there was a rumor going around last year
that I might win an Oscar but nobody
paid the attention to it so I stopped
spreading but it seems to me Jimmy that
they just give awards like for uh for
dramatic pictures and musical epics well
I of course do comedy
really
the last time I babysit for his twins
believe